So when you just compared algorithm A with algorithm B, I guess there were certain parts
of the running time that you did have a look at and that you based your comparison on
and there were other parts that you ignored.
So the parts that you probably ignored are the +10 and the +256 because those are just constants
that we add to the running time function, and also when we compared function,
we didn't really care about the -n or the -50n because we just look at the growth
of the 2n versus 3n².
And even the 3 here is not that important because if we had say 5n² here or 6n² or even 100n²,
2n would still grow much faster.
And this is why in theoretical computer science, we used a notation called Big O-notation
that leads away all those things that we didn't really care about when comparing the algorithms.